so what do you think is going on inside
Boris Johnson's head right now I think
what he's done is take charge this
weekend of a situation that was out of
his control and drifting you know
inevitably towards a very very unhappy
and undignified sort of conclusion and
so if you like he's gone jumping in you
know waving Union Jacks if you like
um rather than be draft kicking and
screaming out of Parliament and though I
won't join those who open exercise the
process and all that I do understand why
he feels uh understandably aggrieved by
the process that has not only taken him
out of office stopped him being prime
minister but now hounded him out of
politics because as you rightly said he
is a man who uh defied political gravity
and only a couple of years or a few
years ago won the biggest majority for
40 years and so I think those people who
voted conservative most of them having
never contemplated voting conservative
before it was very much a personalized
Boris branded pitch at the last election
will feel aggrieved that the man who
they wanted as prime minister is now not
even in Parliament not to mention in M10
I want to get into some of those
processes a bit later in the interview
um he dramatically quit a seat for now
do you think it's going to be back uh
you never know he keeps you know he
deliberately leaves us guessing doesn't
he ask that a vista baby or you know
more classical references it's very
important it's virtually impossible to
to write him off but I don't think this
is part of an elaborate plot to sort of
destabilize and topple Rishi sunak I
think uh Boris Johnson feels that there
is an opportunity for him now to go off
and you know lick his wounds but also
sees New Opportunities is very talented
uh person he's in demand around the
world as a speaker he's writing his
Memoirs he's a great writer so there's a
little time for him to be out of The
Fray but will he come back one day who
knows in other words then is it because
he thinks he would lose the by-elections
in a scene it's a little bit none of us
wants to interview for our own job and
we certainly want to be interviewed for
our own job under the most appalling
circumstances where a committee LED
frankly by a woman who I've got a lot of
threat for but among the many jobs that
Harry Tomlin has done in the past has
been leading the labor party she's
Deputy leader labor party for a long
time can you imagine any labor supporter
being happy if someone like William
Hayes shall we say uh had had the fate
of Kia starmer in his hands when he was
caught drinking beer and having curry
with friends A Long Way from Home in the
middle of lockdown I don't think people
would be comfortable with that process
nor should they be and so I understand
why Boris feels aggrieved and I
understand why a lot of people watching
this will think whoa so committee led by
the former labor leader can actually
Hound Boris out of office when the
police actually found him guilty of one
minor misdemeanor that was worth a 50
Quid fine at the same time it's not just
Harriet Hammond though is it it's a
cross-party group there's a majority of
conservatives on that committee yeah
that doesn't you know that's often a
worse than having your political
opponents there as people from the same
parties as you know better than most um
so if there's so many cross currents in
a party and you know so I don't think
that having a conservative majority
means that you're you know well-being is
is safeguarded it also had to be voted
through by the house as well so he's
assuming that the draw a lot of
considerable number of people on his own
side went back into you I think he's
just thinking do you know the true test
in a democracy is whether the people
vote for you 14 million people voted him
for him pretty much at the last election
they voted for MPS but it was very much
he could have gone to vote in Oxford
which then couldn't he that would be
well he could have done but again you
know in the situation when you are
standing in a by-election under these
sort of circumstances where people are
reading that you've lied to Parliament
because the former leader of the labor
party has decided that you did it's not
ideal to have to reapply for your own
job so I don't blame him at all for just
saying you know Buster because he enough
is enough I'm out of here have you
spoken to him I speak to him from time
to time
um uh and uh you know I think he is
enjoying you know life beyond politics
um his personal life is in a great place
he's going to be a father again uh very
very soon and he's traveling the world
so earning quite a bit of money as well
yeah which which he hasn't done for most
of his life
um now we talked a bit about the party
gate inquiry the other strand of this is
the Honors that Boris Johnson put
forward and this meeting uh between
Rishi sunak and Boris Johnson
um we heard from Grant chap saying that
actually where she seen that didn't get
involved in the process it was all
completely kosher above board perhaps
Boris Johnson didn't understand the
details of what was happening uh like
Grant I wasn't in the room so I don't
know what happened at that meeting
um but uh as I understand it there's
been a lot of touring and throwing about
this list uh and I think the relevant
authorities were not happy with the
scale of it and some of the nominations
originally uh what is nice about the
final list is I look at colleagues who
I've known for a long long time people
who put in an enormous shift at City
Hall 80 years of the mayoralty people
whose names you probably don't know
certainly most of the audience don't but
Boris has in this list taking care of a
whole load of you know decent men and
women who put in an enormous shift
without Fame nor fortune and these
people important to keep the show on the
roads and if we think that politics
matters then we've got to be a little
bit less contemptuous of people engage
in politics whether they're in the back
room or front of house you're on the
list
yes but the real honor for me was having
a chance to serve in number 10 last year
it was brutal it was pretty rough
um but it was also very important and
Boris led the world in helping zelenski
stand up to Putin in the Ukraine he
helped lead Britain out of covid and
unfortunately we crashed into a cost of
living crisis and he got wrestling with
that he was wrestling with energy policy
there was all this stuff going on and
yet if you turned on the television with
some exceptions most of the time all you
would hear was this constant myopic diet
to partygate this party gave that party
gave this party gave that and so he
never had a fair hearing I don't think
uh last year now some of that was partly
of his own making but you know some
things happened before I got there but I
think there was an awful lot to be proud
of that happened last year and a lot for
people like Boris to feel aggrieved of
that it was basically taken away from
him I mean you were there in an absolute
roller coaster at the time weren't you
yeah what do you think was the maddest
day today the most difficult day or
funny enough the moments where I thought
it was lost was when the party when when
those who managed the conservative party
told Boris that they did not want to
oppose this labor motion to set up the
Privileges committee because for me we
had already had a police investigation
we had the sugray inquiry
um there'd been a vote of confidence in
Boris which he won two-thirds of the
party backed him so I thought surely at
this point we can just move on and focus
on what we need to do to sort of
to address the concerns of Voters rather
than the obsessions of the Twitter Arty
and you know I do just want to come back
because because you know when we talk
about party a lot of people saying this
is this is a huge part of our life we
couldn't see loved ones we lost people
without saying goodbye to them and that
goes for him Boris Johnson he lost his
mother I lost my sister it's this
narrative that somehow out there people
were suffering and in here they were
partying hey they were not partying you
know working hard and you've got a 50
Quid fine no that would be the end of
the matter for a civilian but in Boris
Johnson's case something that the police
with all their powers investigation all
the due process and the thoroughness
with which they check things out found
him guilty of something worthy of 50
Quid fine since then he's been hounded
out of office as prime minister and now
handed out of parliament I mean in terms
of proportionality if he was a civilian
um that would be that would be unfair
does he blame Rishi sunak I don't think
he blames uh Rishi sunak
um you know for for much of this he was
very disassemited at the time that Rishi
sunai did not even tell him face to face
that he was resigning I mean because the
other person resigned on that day Sachi
Jared did he was you know man enough if
you like to go and see Boris and tell
him to his face I'm resigning I can't
stand this anymore we discovered on the
Telly that that Rishi had gone so but in
the end the whole party or a big chunk
of the party turned against for us and
that's the reality he's had to wrestle
with but the reason that they did that
is because they couldn't see any other
way of stopping this miserable Purgatory
of turning on the Telly every day and
all they would see is stuff about
partygate and so they decided in the end
whether it's fear or not that they just
couldn't carry on with that the
relationship between Rishi and Boris
Johnson is obviously pretty toxic right
well I sat down with him every morning
you know about 8 15 for seven months of
my life felt like a lot and um
and actually I was surprised when I got
there because I had not met uh Rishi
sunai but the personal chemistry was
very very warm the two of them got on
really well that was at one time it's
now changed well yeah but what I'm
saying is I don't think it's a personal
thing I think it's you know Rishi is now
doing the job that Boris used to do now
none of us feel very good about people
doing that if it's been forced upon us
um I always saw Rishi as the natural
successor but many many years down the
line and actually he cut to the chase
um though actually he wasn't the
beneficiary of the toppling of Boris it
was but he's eventually ended up uh in
power and I wish him well because at
this point in time it is the only game
in town and any conservative who thinks
that prolonging the agony prolonging the
pain prolonging the division dancing on
boris's political grave or undermining
Rishi sunak is mad do you think there's
any way of patching up these warring
sides yes because I think in the end
what we now have is very different we
don't have the Charisma we don't have
the connection we don't have that Unique
Kind of uh
charismatic you're saying oh clearly not
but he's he's hard-working he's clean
living He beavers away and he does
details so the two of them for me were a
perfect tag team you know they
complemented each other's skills very
very well now going into a general
election with Rishi will have certain
disadvantages versus Boris particularly
when you're appealing to working class
blokes across you know swathes of uh the
north of England and the north my native
country Wales
because because they'll miss that sort
of they'll miss that umphrine panas and
and and alpha male them I guess but on
the other hand when you're looking at
the choice between Kia starma and Rishi
sunak you sort of think well actually if
what we need is somebody is capable and
competent and hardworking then
why change you've got Rishi in there
he's young he's bright he's well
qualified particularly to handle the
economy
um and and he's tea total okay
um well that's yeah that is one thing
that he's differs to uh Washington I
guess now just finally you know you've
been we've been talking about the
interview there you've been in the eye
of the storm as director of
communications
how are you finding life on the outside
um I've just been reliving some of my
number 10 days because I've done this
podcast unprecedented and I urge I'm
sure you've listened to it but I urge
anyone wants to understand what really
happened to have a listen because last
year was portrayed in sort of polarized
Extreme Ways and there was a lot more
subtlety to it there was a lot more
texture to it and so I've been reliving
that but otherwise you know I'm doing a
lot more shifts with the rnli where I'm
a volunteer on the Thames uh hopefully
progressing my training there because I
I skimped on my shifts last year and uh
and a lot more time for you know family
and friends always good thank you very
much indeed coming on the program today
thank you good to talk